je suis comme vous j'ai eu envie après
avoir reçu un invité d'en savoir plus
sur sa passion son travail ses amis et
on s'est demandé comment faire dans
l'émission pour tout savoir
même sur notre invité on s'est dit qu'on
allait lui proposer une émission mais on
raccourcit simplement en évoquant les
principales séquences de café picouly à
savoir l'échec et mat
le ping pong la passion d'auteur et le
journal intime est ce soir notre invité
c'est dominique farrugia dominique roja
bonsoir bonsoir la tête marque à chaque
fois je vous et moi annoncé comme un ex
nul
est ce que ça vous ennuie non ça
m'ennuie pas parce que j' aurais dis
surtout pas mon passé je suis très
content d'être exclues les mêmes fier
d'avoir faire partie de ce quatuor de
lutherie voilà alors en ont on en
parlera puisque l'idée c'est de parler
de votre vie à travers ces séquences
c'est quand même une chose qui m'a
étonné dans votre biographie vous êtes
premier prix du conservatoire de flûte
traversière c'est un peu de la connerie
j'ai appris la flûte traversière je suis
allé à l'école normale de musique de
paris pendant un peu de temps mon père
est musicien donc voilà on devait
apprendre un instrument dont j'ai dansé
par le piano ensuite la flûte
ensuite la batterie et puis j'ai
découvert la télévision alors ce qu'on
connaît pas encore que moi je connais
parce que j'ai vu c'est la dernière
pièce que vous avez mis en scène donc et
après au théâtre de la gaîté
montparnasse à une histoire de princesse
on va le dire mais d'abord la
distribution valérie bonneton anne
depetrini helena noguerra et florence
thomassin qui sont tout simplement 4
princesse ouais c'est une magnifique
idée de barbara d'alexandrie et les
deuils guerra qui ont écrit cette pièce
ou juste un point est tu as des filles
que les filles ont fait j'aime par
quelle chance à louisville et puis bien
impliqué très bonne comédienne d'alarmé
la chance était de trouver une trouée
l'idée de dia elles sont mariées elles
ont beaucoup d'enfants et après ils
apprennent et après donc la crise de la
35ème
l'héroïne de conte de fées donc c'était
ses desperate copine villa dans la pièce
à ceyreste desperate housewife qui
rencontrent monty python parce que quand
même il se passe beaucoup de choses
s'il est une ordure un peu à peu c'est
vrai et tout et tout ce mythe lacombe du
conte de fées qui existe chez les filles
qu'on connaît peu nous les connaissons
des gardes et on ne savait pas que
c'était aussi important chez elle alors
pour avoir une idée un petit peu plus
juste de l'ambiance de la pièce on va
regarder tout de suite un extrait de et
après la pièce que vous mettez en scène
au théâtre de la gaîté montparnasse
on regarde cet extrait votre peau d'âne
open your eyes open heures concert
apprête à aurore alors tu vas tu enlever
les doigts du nombril et puis tu vas
faire ta bonne copine
maintenant ma chance mais on ne fait pas
de bébé avec une [ __ ]
quand je pense qu'elle a dormi sentant
elle doit être crohas a terrible
terrible tu vois ta content d'être
authentique or chaque seconde
atchoum est mort bien aimé franchement
la bouche fermée pendant 100 ans
bonjour la laine de poney
correctement là on n'en serait pas là
s'il n'y avait pas eu un pied plus petit
que l'autre blanche qui dit qu'on qu'il
dit couilles qui dit que ça a quelque
chose accomplie non si on a une main qui
s'est mal comporté ça on est tous
d'accord sur le dernier prime c'est peau
d'âne regarde la tête regarde les
cheveux on dirait jean michel jarre
aurore est une folle du cul mais qui s
morts
bon là je crois qu'on a compris on vous
disait monty python vous disais oui et
père noël est une ordure c'est une super
référence merci beaucoup
absolument alors on va voir vous savez
donc le principe de l'émission
donc on va venir tout de suite à notre
séquence échec et mat
l'occasion pour notre invité de revenir
sur un sujet qu'il a heurté et tué
donner envie de pousser un coup de
gueule ou qu'il a particulièrement
touché et pour ça nous mettons cette
petite pendule qui nous rappelle nos
échecs et mat d'antan alors qu'il est
sujet dominique farrugia qui vous à moi
j'étais très très faim je suis fier
d'être français mais j'étais très très
fier d'être français quand mitterrand a
proposé avant d'être élu de mettre un
stop à la peine de mort oui et je trouve
que cet acte politique ou un homme
politique va dans le mur en principe en
proposant ça on a eu pas ce qu'il faut
savoir que l'opinion publique à l'époque
a été majoritairement pour la peine de
mort et bien cet acte politique pour moi
était été grandiose et tout d'un coup ce
n'était pas de la politique marketing
aujourd'hui je trouve qu'on a on fait
figure d'exemple à travers le monde
photo lorsque les états unis exécute
encore des gens il ya des gens dans le
couple dans les couloirs de la mort un
peu partout aux états unis un peu
partout en chine c'est les 68 pays
aujourd'hui à la date d'aujourd'hui
pratique encore la peine de mort je le
sais et c'est pour ça que je me dis
qu'il y a il ya des choses à faire en
politique et qu'on peut faire des choses
et qu'on peut encore abattre des
montagnes
donc s'il vous plaît messieurs les
politiques abate des je trouve le geste
de mitterrand d'annoncer ça
ça dans son programme avant avant les
élections au risque de devoir garder
voire il en a perdu survie certainement
c'était un vrai acte courageux et je
crois que si je respecte profondément
françois mitterrand aujourd'hui c'est
beaucoup à cause de grâce à sa forme la
plus grande erreur judiciaire pour moi
c'est la peine de mort si la seule
manière de condamner un homme séduit
donner la mort je trouve qu'on a ratées
et que c'est un échec de la société et
par exemple dans les prochaines
élections on est quasiment en début de
la campagne
qu'est ce que vous attendez des
politiques comme geste fort mais
quelqu'un d'engagé vous êtes opinions
politiques j'ai des opinions politiques
moi ce que j'aimerais c'est que un de
ses personnages engagé je ne sais pas
lequel sera ni à gauche ni à droite on
ne sait pas encore vous n'avez pas votre
candidat encore vous moi moi non emea
guy bedos crédit c'est très dur d'être
de gauche quand on n'est pas de droite
et je trouve qu'il a raison en ce moment
et je pense que celui qui donnera le
droit de vote aux étrangers pour les
élections communales
celui qui lira averse à versailles et je
sais que sarkozy à penser un moment
bizarrement ce qu'on peut qu'on pourrait
dire ça bizarrement précède on ne peut
pas attendre sa nuit en principe mais il
l'a proposé je trouve que celui qui
renverse versa ça sera un grand pas vous
êtes d'accord vous avez dit votre
admiration pour mitterrand mais ça c'est
une des réformes que la gauche a manqué
une grande réforme que la gauche a
manqué mais ça c'est de la réforme non
électorale
ouais c'est du nom business politique
dangereux c'est c'est dangereux mais
pourquoi un type bien sûr il ne va pas
voter ou des sélections nationales
l'étranger c'est normal linkedin
ils votent dans son pays puis quand ils
payent des impôts locaux dans sa ville
et qu'il n'a pas le droit d'élire son
maire trouve ça dingue pour sa demande
mais à écouter voilà on a je crois votre
idole alors deuxième séquence après
c'était échec et mat tonique ping pong
alors ping pong je vous donne là cette
petite à la voile a pas de stress ou
alors angoisse l'idée c'est de donner
l'occasion à notre invité de revenir sur
un papier cathy qui aurait fait mal
quelque chose d'un peu dur sur lequel il
voudrait revenir ou dont il aimerait
parler est ce que vous avez construit
j'ai gardé la garde et là j'en ai jamais
j'en ai jamais parlé oui mais quand
j'étais patron canal c'était vraiment
difficile
et justement à cette époque là
un type a dit dans un journal il va
partir car il dit qu'il est malade mais
c'est son incompétence qui le met à la
porte et j'ai trouvé ça odieux on peut
me reprocher tout mais me dire que je
vais me cacher derrière ma maladie pour
masquer mon incompétence mais jamais de
la vie
j'ai vu des malades essayons de faire
c'est à ce que j'ai empêché certains
plats que les gens parlent aujourd'hui
très ouvertement mais avant je ne
voulais pas en parler pour que justement
on ne me dise pas oui tu vas faire le
malade non je ne veux pas faire le vin
donc ce journaliste avait quelque chose
qu'ils savaient qu'ils n'avaient pas
divulgué la divulguer il a utilisé il a
utilisé il a utilisé ça et j'ai trouvé
ça pas très fin patrick et puis pas très
bon de la part d'agents dégueulasse quoi
ouais y'a des termes qui se dit oui mais
bon oui hélas quand quand vous les
inquiéter quand vous avez envie de lui
répondre de lui écrire qu est ce que
vous avez fait je lui téléphonais et je
lui ai dit que c'était ignoble alors
réponse il était un peu gêné
ouais je crains mais alors là on parlait
de votre période vous avez été
effectivement directeur de canal vous
avez été directeur de chaîne qui monte
comédie comme audi voilà vous êtes assez
fier parce que vous avez sorti des
talents des talons mais robin des bois
puis même franck dubosc que j'ai produit
titoff pas mal
enfin la période canal + je reprends un
petit bal de pippo passion d'auteur
alors pour notre invité avec ce beau
miroir
l'occasion de parler de quelqu'un pour
lequel il a une grande estime une
passion
alors il ya trois écrivains qui ont
marqué mais d'abord hemingway que que
j'ai dû petit j'ai relu pluvieux et
peut-être que j'avais plein de choses
mais j'ai aimé la mer non non c'est
passé à moi si c'est paris est une fête
qui est qui est mon roman fétiche gm
toutes ces choses qui se passent et puis
sa manière de raconter
cissokho est inventorié aussi de l'homme
well plus l'homme mais pour moi c'est
moi laventure qui m'intéresse chez lui
c'est plus comme qui raconte les
aventures d'hommes
voilà le seul ace dans le sol et
s'élèvent aussi l'impuissance
l'amour c'est magnifique c'est
magnifique qui j'aime moins un côté je
pêche au gros je fume le cigare et voilà
donc d'accord donc premiers émigrés
première des trois alors le greffon tf1
qui va totalement bouleversé jeunes sans
tv et ea et un bouquin qui s'appelle mon
chien stupide qui est une magnifique
réflexion sur le boulot d'écrivains de
cinéma et et et conteur américain
américain mais était totalement désabusé
et voilà ça c'est 2-2 auteurs vraiment
qu'ils m'ont ramené beaucoup de choses
demande à la poussière
voilà j'adore j'adore j'adore ça et puis
récemment bret easton ellis avec avec un
style totalement décalé qui m'emmerde
parfois des parcours avec assor aylagas
est bel et bien il est abrasif
j'adore ça ne laisse pas indifférent
voilà donc c'est que de la littérature
américaine
mais c'est une littérature et que les
éclairer show court donc après cette
passion d'auteurs très américaine le
journal intime alors l'occasion pour
notre invité de nous emmener dans ses
jardins secrets et nous fait rencontrer
quelqu un qu est-ce que vous avez choisi
de ne nous dira j'ai chopé là parce que
la fresque est un peu loin
oui la fresque si si on voit la voix la
fresque à la roue et je crois qu'on la
voit c'est une fresque voilà on est on
est début de siècle
oui
j'ai une vraie vraie passion voire on va
remonter un peu ambiance moulin rouge g
j'ai une vraie passion pour la fin du
19ème et début du xxème pour pour tous
pour tous ces gens là et j'ai une
immense passion aussi pour jean renoir
qui est un cinéaste incroyable par
exemple dans la règle du jeu et ça me
fait penser à ça il collectionne les
automates dit à un moment il a un
limonaire extraordinaire mais vous êtes
un collectionneur nous dingue dingue non
mais alors justement menou dans votre
collection
qu est ce qu on pourrait y voir j'ai
collectionné tous des voitures en
plastique des mickeys beaucoup de mickey
je dois avoir 300 mickey et mickey qui
viennent d'un peu partout je peux la
poser votre collection favori c'était la
caisse celle qui est des films
oui les films des films je ne sais pas
je dois voir 2000 films alors ils sont
bien rangés cas ils sont tous bordélique
chez je suis le roi je suis un mec
totalement désorganisée donc j j'ai la
chance d'avoir chez moi un bureau qui en
même temps ma salle de projection avec
un grand écran tout ça donc ça
s'entassent partout et mon épouse me dit
ce serait bien qu'on roule je dis jamais
imaginons que ce soir au rang de dire je
vais te montrer mon film le fut qu'est
ce qu'on va voir dans ce dans ce magma
je suis sûr que je vous montre la règle
du jeu du renoir j'en suis sûr je le
montre qu'une montre aurait sûrement
hannah et ses soeurs de woody allen qui
est un film moins vu que les autres mais
qui est aussi bon que annie hall et
après si on a le temps se fait des trois
parrains pour terminer c'est génial je
connais les dialogues parker on peut
s'amuser vraiment alors moi je voulais
vous remercier parce que voilà vous avez
je crois donné beaucoup de vous ce soir
et alors je voudrais revenir sur cette
pièce
ces jeunes filles avec ces jeunes femmes
avec lesquelles vous avez le bonheur de
travailler
valérie bonneton anne depetrini helena
noguerra florence thomassin dans une
pièce de barbara d'alessandrini mise en
scène par dominique farrugia est entouré
et l'état et la dette qui met en scène
avec moi j'aime et qui met en scène avec
vous j'adore ces jeunes femmes quand
même et des chances et bien sûr c'est
pas fini projet juste avant de finir au
plein de trucs l'intrus plein de trucs
donc on se revoit bientôt ici je reviens
boire un coup et d'accord avec vous en
pensez vous
[Musique]